36 years since high-flying speeds to
maverick first rocketed across the big
screen he's back but will the sequel
take your breath away or is it writing
checks it can't cash yipikai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
comparing top gun maverick to the 80s
original revealing the biggest
differences and whether it's a worthy
sequel some spoilers ahead so take care
since tom cruise last slipped on those
aviators a lot has changed top gun took
the young actor born on the 3rd of july
1962 and made him a huge star and at
nearly 60 years of age he's back to show
he can still turn and burn with the best
of them including those almost half his
age i can hold my own and like his
character maverick the american-made
mega star actor seems happiest when he's
going mac 2 with his hair on fire except
in the new movie he actually gets to go
way faster than that though maverick
decided to become a top gun instructor
in 1986 god help us we find out he only
did that for a couple of months and as
he wanted to keep flying satisfying his
need for speed rather than rising
through the navy ranks you should be at
least a two-star admiral by now yet here
you are captain he's now a test pilot
until he's called back to top gun for
some intense training teaching a new
crop of graduates his inverted ways
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they going to get to teach
us and while he certainly still has his
rebellious side
he's not quite as hot-headed or focused
on himself as he once was it's not your
flying it's your attitude sure he was
already stepping up by the end of the
original but now time's past and he's
grown up and into his responsibilities
though he died in the first film nick
bradshaw aka goose pops up in flashback
memories and photos showing how maverick
is still tormented by his best friend's
death and goose lives on in his son
bradley aka rooster who popped up
briefly as a child back in the 1986
movie and is now a top gun pilot
rooster's a chip off the old block
there's that mustache and hair the
hawaiian shirt and he sings great balls
of fire at the piano which apparently
miles teller learnt for the movie and
plays for real obviously given their
history maverick's relationship with
rooster is more complicated than it was
with goose expect lots of drama
including a heady mix of resentment
guilt and a barrel full of tension
between them plus his father's fate
means both that rooster can be a bit
more cautious flying compared to other
pilots and that maverick wants to look
out for him like a father figure
maverick's old nemesis iceman is now an
admiral and is crucial to the plot as he
insists on mav being posted back to top
gun to train its graduates for a complex
special mission you were here at the
request of iceman he seems to think that
you have something left to offer the
navy actor val kilmer returns in a short
but touching cameo which sees the
friends and former rivals discuss the
dangerous new operation and their shared
past much of iceman's side of the
conversation is tapped out on a computer
as kilmer's real-life experience with
throat cancer is woven into his
character's story the whole scene is
particularly poignant especially for
fans who grew up watching the original
film you can be my wingman anytime you
can be mine as for the spirit of the
young 1980s iceman that lives on in
hangman a cocky new top gun graduate
played by glenn powell what do we have
here yeah here i thought we were special
fellas this here's bagman hangman whose
hostility towards rooster has definite
shades of iceman and maverick back in
the day with a neat twist on the 80s
plot while val kilmer returns in person
and a young anthony edwards and his
on-screen wife meg ryan return in
flashbacks the original film's female
lead astrophysicist and top gun civilian
contractor charlie played by kelly
mcgillis isn't even name-dropped in
passing despite her a maverick ending up
together instead cruz's on-screen love
interest this time is penny benjamin
owner of aviators club the hard deck who
was briefly mentioned in the first movie
and one admiral's daughter penny
benjamin and is now brought to life by
jennifer connolly while there was no
previous history between charlie and
maverick when they kicked off their
romance back in the 80s penny and
maverick's relationship has been on and
off many times over the years but maybe
now it's time to fly off into the sunset
both military and movie technologies
come a long way since the mid-80s and
that's clearly reflected in the sequel
while for other movies that might mean
stacks of cgi sequences this is a tom
cruise production an actor who's not
just known for his star power but also
for his perfectionism and punch on for
old school movie making so the emphasis
is very much on doing as many practical
stunts as possible in fact cruz who's
famous for doing lots of his own action
on land and in the air reportedly also
took the time to create bespoke aviation
programs for the movie's young cast who
did several months of intense flight
training that meant that while the
planes were flown by real navy pilots
the filmmakers were able to shoot the
young actors in the air really reacting
to the need for speed in other words the
kind of stomach churning g-force they'd
feel in real life the result is that
often it feels as if you're in the air
with them soaring and diving through the
skies during the movie's plentiful
scenes of fast-paced aerobatics and
dogfights which are exactly the kind of
thing made to be seen on the most
massive screen available as well as the
newer planes appearing in the sequel one
of the main fighter aircrafts from the
80s movie the f-14 tomcat is back in
action and also just like in the 80s the
enemy remains nameless understandably
given the first film was introducing
audiences to the world of the navy's
fighter weapons school for the first
time that movie focuses more on training
exercises for general missions and
infighting among students vying to be
top dog however the new film raises the
stakes much earlier on with maverick
preparing the latest batch of top gun
graduates for a very specific almost
impossible mission that will see them
zooming slap bang into the middle of a
real danger zone we're going into combat
on a level no living pilot's ever seen
not even him as well as all the 21st
century twists on the original movie
there's also a hefty hit of nostalgia in
terms of callbacks from plot and
character-driven details to nods to tony
scott's endless stylish sunset scenes
and beachside fun and games and of
course is it even a tom cruise movie
without at least one scene of him
running the superstar actor producer
also brings together more than a few
good men and women both behind and in
front of the camera creating a more
diverse cast though as you'd expect it's
maverick who gets the lion's share of
screen time followed by rooster of
course bringing back a character from
long ago a legend who's the object of
endless love is a very risky business
with plenty of potential for fallout for
every movie that taps into that perfect
night and a cocktail of old and new
providing something both for long-term
fans and the outsiders to the franchise
there are many more that prove that
losing it all is a very real possibility
big success requires making all the
right moves if you want to end up far
and away from falling into oblivion now
cruz once said he'd never go back to top
gun but there'll be a lot of fans today
glad he changed his mind as along with
masses of action the sequel brings a
good deal more humor and heart and no
pressure on the sequel but the original
movie's iconic soundtrack is one of the
best-selling soundtrack albums of all
time mixing songs written for the film
like danger zone with classic tracks
from artists such as the righteous
brothers and otis redding the 80s
soundtrack also nabbed an oscar and
golden globe for berlin's romantic theme
take my breath away and a grammy for the
top gun anthem the new film also mixes
old and new with the likes of kenny
loggins and david bowie featuring
alongside the power ballad hold my hands
sung and co-written by lady gaga who's
no stranger to winning awards herself
and the same goes for hans zimmer who
scored the sequel along with the
originals composer harold faltermeyer as
for danger zone tom cruise insisted the
song had to be in the film as it
wouldn't be a top gun movie without it
and thanks to this video sponsor nordvpn
you can avoid ending up in the online
danger zone nord have just launched
their new threat protection feature
which blocks trackers making your online
experience a lot cleaner safer and
enjoyable so next time you accidentally
stumble across a shady site or a fishing
link nord's threat protection will
neutralize and destroy the threat like
it's seeking out an enemy jet scanning
any downloaded files for malware and
deleting them immediately on top of that
nord encrypts your internet connection
and conceals your ip address so you can
keep all your online activity private it
stops your internet service provider
from knowing what websites you visit and
nord's threat protection will also block
those third-party cookies that follow
you around the web bombarding you with
incredibly intrusive ads with nord you
can connect up to six devices at any one
time so you can protect all your phones
laptops and computers for a limited time
all our viewers can grab an exclusive
offer on a two-year plan with a huge
discount plus a bonus month and threat
protection completely free just visit
nordvpn.comflix or go to the link in the
video description to get the offer or
use coupon code flicks when you check
out so movie lovers what do you think of
the top gun sequel and how does it
compare to the original let me know
below and if you liked this video do
leave a thumbs up i really appreciate
him next tap left to discover the doctor
strange multiverse of madness deleted
scenes that marvel cut from the film
thanks for enjoying this movie with me
and hope you have a marvellous movie
loving week yipikai movie lovers
you